[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In this video,
we're going to be showing you
how to make some magical
solar-powered lights.
They're quick to make,
cost less than three dollars a piece,
and there are decoration
that can really give
your party a magical pop.
[Music]
To get started making these
magical outdoors solar lights,
there's three main things
that you need to grab.
One is some small mason jars.
The second is some solar stake lights,
and the third is some
clear cellophane plastic.
Here's the basic idea.
A solar stake light will be dismantled,
and some of the important pieces
will be glued to the inside
of a mason jar and its lid.
Some crumpled colored cellophane
will be added to give the lights
a magical otherworldly effect.
Decorative elements can
then be added to the lid
to give your lights a bit more style.
Little mason jars are
available in lots of places,
and I got these specific
ones at Hobby Lobby
because I really like the short design
and the square sides that it has.
There are also multiple
different sizes of lids,
and you want to make sure
that you have the ones
that fit nicely with your solar lights.
These little stake lights cost a dollar.
They have a stake at the bottom,
and you can stab them into the ground
and making a nice lining your path.
Well, we're not going to be
using all of the equipment,
and certainly not the stakes,
but we are going to
disassemble these for parts.
These solar stakes are
fairly easy to disassemble,
and the only tool we're going to need
to get all the parts that we need
is a simple Phillips-head screwdriver.
[Music]
These right here are the
two pieces that we're going for.
This has a solar panel,
a sensor to see how much light there is,
and on the bottom,
there's an LED bulb.
This tag here on the side prevents
the battery from connecting to the bulb
while it's still in the store.
But once we pull that out,
it should light up
when we've got the
solar panel blocked off.
It's a pretty straightforward design.
The solar panel on top charges
a 1.2 volt battery inside,
and there's an ambient
light detector in the lid,
so that when it's too dark,
the light turns on automatically.
We want these two pieces,
and the rest of the
stake can be discarded.
This shiny little piece
sits down below the lightbulb,
and it's a reflector
to make sure you get the most
out of your one LED bulb.
With the mason jars, I talked about
the lid fitting onto the top of the lantern,
and if you have the right size,
you'll have an incredibly close fit
that barely has any space on the sides.
The inner lid of our mason jar,
like the rest of the stake,
can be discarded.
Once we've got these
four pieces separated,
it's time to use a hot glue gun
to start assembling them.
This small chrome piece
is still going to be a reflector,
the same way it was before,
just in a different place.
We want to glue this onto the
center bottom of our mason jar.
[Music]
Next, we want to take the
top portion of the lantern,
fit it just slightly
inside the mason jar lid,
and then glue it in place.
If you need to,
you can glue it from the outside.
But it's going
to look a little sloppy.
So I really like to try and get all
of the glue on the interior of the lid.
[Music]
It's daylight out here,
so it's pretty hard to see how
much it does or does not light up.
Let's put this jar inside
of a darkened block
so we can get a better sense for it.
The white light and
unobscured walls of the glass
means we are still losing
a fair amount of the light out the sides.
To keep it more visible,
and of course, to add a little bit
of sparkling magical looking color,
that's where the cellophane comes in.
This whole roll,
which has quite a bit on it,
was only about two dollars,
and we're not going to be
using anywhere near a whole roll.
Not even the tenth probably.
We want to cut a piece of cellophane,
and wrinkled it in sort
of a circle around the reflector.
We don't want to obscure
the path of light
from the LED down to the
reflector at the bottom.
But we want all the way around the
sides to be covered in our cellophane.
[Music]
Now, this piece is maybe 8 inches tall,
and a little over a foot wide.
It's not necessarily going to
matter exactly what size you get.
I'm just kind of going
to crumple this up,
and then push it into the jar,
in sort of a loop around
the reflector at the bottom.
[Music]
With the cellophane added,
we can now screw the lantern light lid
down onto the jar.
[Music]
The cellophane comes
in several different colors.
And if you aren't a big fan
of the look of a mason jar,
especially with its gold or silver lid,
here's plenty of ways
you can decorate those.
Ribbon, twine, or paint all work great.
[Music]
By combining colors of cellophane,
you can get some interesting
blends that look even more exotic.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all.
We've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top of will
transport directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching next,
and this bomb in the middle
will subscribe you to the channel,
that way you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.